[Music]
and working pretty hard I'm getting a
little tired so I figured I should
probably get some coffee you may have
noticed that your screen is a bit
different today you're actually watching
a 3d 180 degree VR video YouTube
approached us and asked if we would be
interested in experimenting with a
prototype camera to make an entire vlog
width it was an interesting proposal so
we rigged it up to a gimbal and tried to
see if it was possible this is not a
sponsored video by the way
[Music]
I paint on my hands I took my ring off
to wash my hands and I set out on the
table on the back properly and I forgot
to put it back on and then at some point
in the day somebody else knocked it off
the tables and there that evening I
realized that I was missing my ring and
I went outside and I looked for it and
looked around all the desks I couldn't
find it and I was like well it might
just be gone thing is I'm planning on
getting like a nicer one to like
actually wear everyday so wasn't like
the biggest deal in the world it was
gone but still kind of stuck because
it's a sentimental thing the tricky
thing is is it to ask yourself is a
risk/reward scenario do I not tell ivy
in hope she doesn't notice and either
hope to a find the ring or buy the other
ring at time that I stopped wearing this
one and thereby escaped unscathed
without getting in trouble or do I tell
her get in trouble but much less trouble
than I would be in if she found out say
a week down the line
I lost the ring a week ago and didn't
tell her so it was really like there's a
really big conundrum as in do I tell her
- I don't tell her and well guys I'm a
risk taker some didn't tell her and then
sure enough this morning I come in in
Carmichael goes hey Nico are you missing
something I guess I am
and he hands me the ring he saves my
life today sword fighting in the office
[Music]
she's dead I'm gonna put this on the
corridor card all right sounds good what
are you getting we validate this ticket
yeah
[Music]
we're here to try the brand-new
pineapple mango cream I've no idea what
[Music]
just like a one of those orange cream
bars yeah exactly
[Music]
mango this is like weird it's like
there's creamy bits Minh there's also
really really intense mango bits it's
hard to do with one hand all right Nick
what should we do now should we just go
riding around Little Tokyo check out a
little tokes
yeah let's go check out
[Music]
Nick Nick
smooth routine of coming up with wacky
ideas and executing on them it's kind of
a creative groove after lifeline I feel
myself in but yeah right now I'd say
this is this beast movie idea that we're
working on right now is the main thing
taking over my life what's the biggest
hurdle that you guys are facing right
now in development of that right now
there's not hurdles so to speak as it is
just simply making it you know like we
are trying to make it making a project
that big is a lot work so ya gotta start
somewhere and that somewhere is anywhere
but just doing something really let us
know what you think about this
experiment down below and if you want to
see us do more interesting camera
experiments in the future please
consider subscribing
[Music]